We are going to go right back to the phones
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 and see what is on people's
minds.
Let's go to our caller from the 8 1 5 area
code who's calling today from 8 1 5.
Is that me?
Yes, it is.
Hi, so I have a two part question here.
OK.
Your loadouts simliar with basically how the.
All right.
Pipelined were a few years ago like I've even
seen you do videos.
Yep.
We bought some billables remote.
Something similar is happening in the opposite
direction.
Oh, I don't mean like the conservative idea
of anything even remotely progressive is socialist.
I mean, you think there is now a similar pipeline
that is turning people into actual socialist
actual communists?
Well, the thing about calling it a pipeline,
I mean.
So, listen, there are people that go into
and come out of a political ideology all the
time.
There are people that become outright and
people that stop being all right outright.
There are people that become socialists and
who stop being socialist, et cetera.
That's normal.
The question about calling it a pipeline to
me is more one about.
Is there a particular path that we can identify
that is either happening through like proactive
propaganda movements or indoctrination movements,
disinformation or simply like algorithms online?
I mean, I'm open to the idea that there is
something similar going on with socialism.
I'm just I'm just not aware of it.
I mean, cert-, certainly there's socialist
voices on Web sites like YouTube and Reddit
and Twitter.
And you can certainly create an echo chamber
for yourself of socialist voices, whether
there's a pipeline persay.
I don't I guess I don't have enough information
to say.
What do you have in mind?
What do you identify as that pipeline?
Well, the biggest pieces of evidence of this,
in my opinion, are the rise of a lot of popular,
virtually socialist content online.
Like there's tons of socialist YouTubers out
there with tens, if not hundreds of thousands
of.
All both ugly, just blowing Albar lol.
Well, Southern part of this question would
be do you feel this is a good or bad for the
last in America?
Well, there's two that depend, so I am not
a socialist.
So if the question is, do I think the Democratic
Party needs to start running on socialism?
My personal answer is no, but that's not happening.
If the question is, are we better off if more
people are exposed to the ideas of socialism
and understand them for what they are rather
than the cartoonish cartoon ified things that
the right likes to say, I'm all for that.
Yeah, that's more my question.
OK.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I listen.
I took Marxian economics at the University
of Massachusetts as an undergraduate.
My my professors there were Richard Wolfe,
the socialist economist and the late Steve
Resnick, and it was one of the few schools
that was actually offering as part of their
economics department.
Serious classes on Marxian economics.
And I'm better for it.
It didn't turn me into a socialist, but I
now understand some about those ideas.
I think that's great.
Just clarify, some people are real glad, are
not inherently opposed to socialism.
OK, but I think the spreading of these socialist
ideas online is causing a lot of people on
the left to act in ways that are tilers counter-productive.
Like, for example, I'm actually a few socialist
discord of us.
You have a better socialist content creators.
Yeah, and it's a very common narrative there
that basically electorial isn't bad.
There's no point in participating in this
award show.
The only way we're going to get real change
is this.
We take direct action outside of the system.
Don't bother voting for by then.
It won't matter.
OK, so let me let me address that.
So here, here's the thing.
Every movement is going to create some very
loud people who will turn.
What you're describing is acceleration.
It's basically like working within the system
no longer works.
You need to destroy the system.
That's not unique to socialism.
Right.
I mean, with the Tea Party, extremists also
had a component of acceleration.
This stuff about ways in which society needs
to be broken down and sort of like rebuilt.
White supremacists fundamentally are talking
about significantly acceleration ist ideas
in many.
I don't think it would be unfair to say that
that's unique to socialism.
There are certainly people who who start following
socialist theory learning about it, and they
end up in what you're talking about.
That's not most of them.
And I don't think that that is the case.
We could say that that's unique to socialism.
Level involved, although it should be a particularly
worried about one, I don't think we need to
be more worried about extremist socialists
than we need to be worried about extremist
libertarians or extreme, you know, whatever.
I think that at the extremes of most movements,
you will find people whose ideas are very
unlikely to ever really be mainstreamed and
to put too much emphasis on them probably
probably doesn't make sense.
Listen, I appreciate the call.
I do want to move on because I've got some
other people that want to get on here.
Very important topics for sure.
Let's go to our caller from the six, seven,
eight area code who's calling today from 6,
7, 8.
Six, seven, eight.
Hey, how are you?
Who's this?
This is Matt from Tulsa.
Hey, Max, what's up?
Hey, I was just wondering what your thoughts
were on.
It's seemingly Republican states, red states
are opening up rather fast and it seems like.
It seems like the media and just the general
population of the country, even if even if
case rates are going up and deference is going
up, it doesn't really seem to hit home with
a lot of people.
You know, if you don't lose a loved one or
something like that.
So as case, even if chase rates do keep spiking
and going up and as states continue to open
D.C. down the line in the November election,
if we have it on time.
Maybe Trump gaining ground and gaining approval
with his denial of, you know, that there's
actually a problem and maybe red states to
be flourishing a little bit more.
And if we keep it under, you know, it could
keep hospitals from capsizing over their limit.
Yeah.
Good.
Okay.
A very good question.
So there's there's two ways that this could
go.
Now, let me make clear.
I would love it.
I would genuinely love it if all of these
red states that open up don't see a resurgence.
I would love to see that it doesn't happen
and that things just go great.
And then blue states can open up and then
everything's lovely.
And then we go and hopefully we remove Donald
Trump in November anyway.
But your question is a good one, which is
if the numbers do keep getting worse in these
red states and it's already happening to some
degree.
It's happening in Texas, it's happening in
Georgia, Tennessee is increasingly a disaster,
etc.
I think in the short term, Trump's strategy
will work, which is normalize it, pretend
everything's fine, OK?
I mean, yes, some people are dying, but this
is the new normal status quo.
I think it will work for four weeks, six weeks,
maybe eight weeks.
But when it continues and then you also get
the disastrous second quarter GDP numbers
in August, I don't think it's going to work
for Donald Trump to just keep insisting everything's
fine.
I don't think it's a short term play.
If by chance there are no resurgence is grim
opening, I'll be happy because I don't want
there to be.
But it will work out for Trump.
To some degree.
Otherwise, I think it eventually will completely
backfire on him.
Yeah.
I don't see how how it won't, I guess if hospitals
do end up keeping it under the limits where,
you know, they're at least functioning.
Yeah, I guess we could.
But yeah.
All right, my friend, very good, I appreciate
the phone call.
Thank you so much.
L